[Applaus]
[Musik]
und seine linksradikalen verrückten
führen die US Open also mal wieder in
den Abgrund natürlich wenn Donald Trump
2025 wieder Präsident werden und dies zu
verhindern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist am Ende also wirklich wieder zurück
ins Weiße Haus schaffen und was würde
dies für die USA und die Welt bedeuten
klar ist die Rückkehr der magerpolitik
also make America great again wäre ein
weiterer mega Boost für den
amerikanischen Isolationismus
Protektionismus und die Globalisierung
die hauptleitragenden wären die auf
Freihandel und Export angewiesen
Regionen also China und Europa
insbesondere Deutschland wir haben diese
Zusammenhänge erst kürzlich in einem
eigenen Video auf unserem schwesterkanal
visualökonomic dargelegt ich werde es
Euch natürlich verlinken auch die
Ukraine müsste mit weniger Waffenhilfe
rechnen als unter beiden Putin bekäme
wohl mehr Raum für seinen
expansionistischen Militarismus auch
wenn Trump damit trotzdem würde als
US-Präsidentin 24 Stunden beenden können
wenn ich Präsident wäre hätte es den
Russland Ukraine Krieg nie gegeben aber
selbst jetzt wenn ich Präsident wäre
könnte ich innerhalb von 24 Stunden ein
Ende dieses schrecklichen und schnell
eskalierenden Krieges aushandeln man
muss sie nur beide in einen Raum bringen
und es gibt Dinge die man ihnen sagen
kann die ich jetzt nicht verraten werde
die garantieren dass dieser Krieg so
fort beendet wird der dritte Weltkrieg
war noch nie so nah wie in diesem Moment
trotz Verhandlungsstrategie wenn sie
denn überhaupt existierte bleibt also
sein Geschäftsgeheimnis bisher ist nur
so viel durchgesickert auf der einen
Seite führt er die Angst vor einem
Dritten Weltkrieg und auf der anderen
sitzend er herum die USA sollten
Russland als Vergeltung für den Überfall
auf die Ukraine in Schutt und
aschebomben und zwar mit F22 Jahren
unter falscher chinesischer Flagge dann
könnte man sich zurücklehnen und
genüsslich zugucken wie Russland und
China aufeinander losgingen man sieht
also Trump ist nicht nur einfach zurück
sondern er ist mit all seiner
strategischen Unberechenbarkeit geradezu
entfesselt und das auch innenpolitisch
er wiederholt seine Theorie vom
Wahlbetrug im Jahr 2020 wie ein Mantra
und hat wie aus dem Putsch Lehrbuch
sogar gefordert dass die Verfassung der
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika nicht
respektiert werden sollte
werden die Ergebnisse der
Präsidentschaftswahlen von 2020
verworfen und der Gerechte Gewinner
erklärt oder gibt es eine neue Wahl eine
massiver betrug dieser Art und diesen
Ausmaßes erlaubt die Aufhebung aller
Regeln Vorschriften und Artikel sogar
derjenigen die in der Verfassung stehen
Donald Trump Schere sich einen Dreck
darum ob Gerichte und offizielle
Untersuchungen seine betrugstheorie
widerlegt haben der ehemalige Präsident
scheint sich über Regeln Gesetze und die
Verfassung selbst stellen zu wollen denn
wenn sie seinen Interessen nicht
dienlich sind nutzen Sie überhaupt nicht
die Verfassung ist größer als jeder
Präsident Ende der Diskussion Elon Musk
es gab eine Zeit in der dieses Verhalten
die Beleidigungen und ständigen Lügen
mit dem Hinweis gerechtfertigt wurden
dass das alles letztendlich Teil der
Show sein ein Weg um die Massen
aufzuwickeln und einen politischen
Diskurs ohne Angst und Unterwerfung
unter die politische Korrektheit führen
zu können
muss jedoch ihre Grenzen haben und der
Angriff auf das Kapitol in Washington
bei den vier Menschen ums Leben kamen
und infolgedessen sich vier
Polizeibeamter das Leben nahmen hat klar
gezeigt dass trumpshow die Grenzen des
Erträglichen und legitimen längst
überschritten hat leider hat Donald
Trump dies nicht begriffen nein er ist
wie gesagt entfesselter denn je Trump
drückt seine Unterstützung für die
Capitol Krawallmacher aus während er
weiterhin die Unterstützung
extremistische Gruppen willkommen heißt
der ehemalige Präsident behauptet dass
die Menschen die an dem Angriff auf das
Kapitol beteiligt waren ungerecht
behandelt worden er sagt dass seine
Kampagne einige der Haupt Angeklagten
unterstützt und er hat sogar gnädigungen
versprochen falls er ins Weiße Haus
zurückkehren sollte und bedenkt dass er
diesen schicksalhaften sechsten Januar
vielleicht zu einer der sollen seiner
Kampagne machen will auf diese Weise
könnte er weiterhin das System anfangen
und gleichzeitig seinen eigenen
Schutzschild aus fanatischen Realisten
aufbauen stark radikalisierten
Aktivisten die bei den Vorwahlen
Republikaner eine wichtige Rolle spielen
könnten dies würde auch erklären warum
der ehemalige Präsident seine neue
politische Kampagne mit einem Abendessen
in Gesellschaft ist wegen
antisemitischen Ausfällen aufgefallenen
Rappers keine West und eines gewissen
Nick Freundes begann einen Bekannten
Neonazi der vor dem Angriff auf das
Kapitol an Jumps Kundgebung teilnahmen
die radikalisierter seine Basis ist
desto besser scheint er sich zu denken
[Musik]
Trump hat dazu beigetragen
Verhaltensweisen zu normalisieren wie zu
jeder anderen Zeit nicht akzeptabel
gewesen wären und wie der Gesellschaft
als Ganzes Schaden Amerika wird nun mehr
also nicht nur von der radikalen Linken
mit ihrer aggressiv toxischen wirkness
in Geiselhaft genommen und zu perversen
Verhaltensänderungen gezogen sondern
gleichzeitig auch von einem
aufgepeitschten pervers orthodoxen
Konservatismus beide Strömungen scheinen
immer mehr gewaltbereit zu sein hätten
ihre Unterstützer immer stärker
gegeneinander und gegen die Mitte auf
und sie geraten immer mehr außer
Kontrolle wobei sie die bürgerliche
liberale Mitte nebenbei zwischen sich
zusammen das Motto lautet wer nicht für
uns ist ist gegen uns
[Musik]
dies alles hat auch viel mit dem
us-wahlsystem zu tun welches der
Radikalisierung von Kandidaten in
Vorwahlen Vorschub leistet wir haben
darüber schon vor einiger Zeit ein Video
gedreht dass ich euch verlinken werde
und dass ihr euch unbedingt ansehen
solltet um die Problematik besser zu
verstehen fakt ist Trump hat es
geschafft dieses System optimal
auszunutzen und die republikanische
Parteiführung vor sich her zu treiben
auf diese Weise hat er ihr sowohl seine
Dogmen als auch seine konfliktträchtige
Art aufgezwungen jeder Republikaner der
in der Partei aufsteigen möchte muss ihn
nun nach dem Mund reden auch wenn er ihn
selbst lieber loswerden würde der
Hauptgrund Trump weiß noch immer die
Mehrheit der Partei Basis hinter sich
und du den Ernstfall sogar mit Partei
Austritt was erst recht zu einer
Inklusion der Republikaner ja der
gesamten rechten führen würde denn ein
entscheidender Prozentsatz der Wähler
und Mitglieder der Grand old Party liebt
gerade zu Trumps Slogans und Stil und
Sie werden bei den primaris das Zünglein
an der wahr sein jeder potentielle
republikanische Kandidat wird also wie
Donald Trump sein müssen am besten
jedoch noch radikale trotz aller
Fehltritte und Skandale die sich Trump
seit seiner Niederlage bei den
Präsidentschaftswahlen geleistet hat
steht also eines fest ein Jahr vor den
Beginn der Vorwahlen zur nächsten
Präsidentschaft 2024 ist alles mögliche
Trump und sein wahrscheinlicher
Widersacher Randy Säntis führen bei den
Meinungsumfragen einen Kopf an Kopf
rennen
[Musik]
1 März 2023 Trump übernimmt in vier
wichtigen Umfragen die Führung vor die
Centers laut einer Umfrage des Amazon
College wird Trump von 55%
republikanischen wählerunterstützt eine
weitere Umfrage von yogave ergab dass
der Ex-Präsident bei den
republikanischen Vorwahl Wählern einen
Vorsprung von 8% Punkten vor dezentes
hat damit kehrte sich das Ergebnis einer
früheren Umfrage um nach der der
Gouverneur von Florida 4% Punkte vor
Trump lag das republikanische
Meinungsforschungsinstitut eschel und
insights veröffentlichte ebenfalls eine
Umfrage die dem ehemaligen Präsidenten
einen Vorsprung von 15 Punkten gegenüber
dezentes bescheinigt 46% gegenüber nur
31%. das sind ganze 13 Punkte mehr für
Trump als die gleiche Umfrage im letzten
Monat ergab man sieht also es ist viel
in Bewegung der vormalige Präsident
Trump könnte also durchaus auch der
nächste Präsident der USA werden
andererseits hat sein Chef der
Kontrahent bei den republikanischen
Vorwahlen London ist dann Kandidatur
noch nicht mal angekündigt könnte doch
so manchen Joker aus dem ärmelzauber das
alles ist Grund genug für uns das Thema
mal so richtig auseinander zu nehmen im
heutigen Video werden wir uns daher vor
allem erstmal Donald Trump widmen im
nächsten dann die Säntis unter die Lupe
nehmen wäre die Säntis in der Lage Trump
eine empfindliche Niederlage zu
bescheren was sind Trumps Schwachstellen
welche Überraschungen könnten wir
erleben all diese spannenden Fragen
werden wir in diesem Video beantworten
und zwar gleich nach einem wichtigen
Hinweis unseres Sponsors inkognin wisst
ihr eigentlich was data Broker sind also
datenmakler das sind Unternehmen die
überall persönliche Daten über uns
ausführen und einsammeln z.B auf
öffentlich zugänglichen Datenbanken aus
unserem vorverhalten im Netz oder wenn
man mal dummerweise an einem Gewinnspiel
teilgenommen hat sie sammeln und
verknüpfen diese Daten um sie dann
auszuwerten und an andere Unternehmen zu
verkaufen das können dann durchaus
seriöse sein oder aber auch Betrüger die
uns mit unerwünschten Anrufen SMS und
E-Mails bombardieren oder gar nicht
nehmen wollen das Problem ist niemand
von uns kann wissen an wen ein Broker
unsere Daten verkauft wir haben null
Kontrolle darüber was wir aber tun
können ist sie zu kontaktieren und sie
aufzufordern unsere Daten bei sich zu
löschen denn dazu sind Sie gesetzlich
verpflichtet dabei stoßen wir jedoch auf
ein weiteres Problem es gibt nämlich
tausende dieser data Broker und sie alle
wollen auf unterschiedliche Weise
kontaktiert werden und manchmal lesen
Sie die Anfrage einfach ab und man muss
sich dann überlegen wie man damit umgeht
kurz um es handelt sich um eine süße
Fußarbeit und wäre es nicht toll das
Ganze zu automatisieren quasi als
Dienstleistung ja jetzt kommt die gute
Nachricht diese Dienstleistung gibt es
und es handelt sich um kein geringeren
als den Sponsor dieses Videos in KODi du
meldest dich einfach bei ihm irgendwie
an und beauftragt sie in deinem Namen
bei den data Brokern aufzuräumen und
schon geht's los auf eine
übersichtlichen Dashboard kannst du
sehen bei welchen data broken sich deine
Daten gefunden haben wie sie Kontakt mit
Ihnen aufnehmen und wieder Fortschritte
löschen Anträge verläuft und dann
bekommst du E-Mails von diesen
Unternehmen in den steht wir haben Ihre
Daten gelöscht ist das nicht eine
Wohltat die traurige wahr mit unserer
Welt ist nun mal wenn man all diese
Löschanträge manuell stellen wollte
würde diesen Monate dauern etwas was
kein normaler Mensch auf sich nehmen
würde also haben sich alle damit
abgefunden dass Ihre Daten draußen
herumgeistern und missbraucht werden tja
bis jetzt schaut euch also unbedingt das
Angebot von inkognit über den Link in
der Beschreibung zu diesem Video an dort
findest du auch den Promo Code
politik.de und wenn du zu den ersten 100
gehörst die nutzen gibt dir inkognit 20
% Rabatt ist doch nicht Wahr und falls
Ihr uns etwas Nettes tun wollt ebenfalls
in der Beschreibung unter diesem Video
findet ihr einen Spenden Link mit helfen
könnte unsere Videos zu finanzieren so
und nun ab nach Amerika wo willst du
nicht die Tiefen und und Tiefen des
Donald Trump erkunden werden
pro der geborene Gewinner oder Verlierer
Donald Trumps politische Karriere als
Spitzenkandidat Republikaner begann
nicht erst am 15 Juni 2015 als Trump
erstmal seine Kandidatur für die
republikanischen Vorwahlen ankündigte
und mexical senses people Dinner sending
the best der sending
peoples
Problem
ist nein seine politische Karriere
begann schon viel früher bereits am 19
November 2012 ein paar Tage nach dem
Barack Obama mit Ronny im Kampf um die
Präsidentschaft besiegt hatte meldete
Trump nämlich den bekannten Slogan make
and America greate again als
Markenzeichen an ein wahllos mit den er
es gegen alle Widerstände geschafft hat
2016 zum 55 Präsidenten der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika gewählt zu werden
und zwar dank eines sehr unerwarteten
Wahlausgang ermöglichte die
normalerweise demokratischen Staaten
Pennsylvania mischingen und ist Konsum
mit einer Handvoll Stimmen zu gewinnen
es war ein knapper Sieg aber es war ein
Sieg damals das Unmögliche möglich
gemacht zu haben
heute liegen die Dinge jedoch etwas
anders und wisst ihr was wir können drei
Hauptgründe nennen warum es für Trump
sehr viel schwieriger sein wird auch nur
als Kandidat der Republikaner
zurückzukehren ganz zu schweigen von
einer Rückkehr ins Weiße Haus denn im
letzten Jahr sorgte der trumpismus für
Nachrichten wie diese 7 dezember 2022
Demokraten erweitern zenats Mehrheit
nach gewonnener Stichwahl in Georgia
georgia ist traditionell eine hochportal
Republikaner doch beiden hat die 2020
gegen alle Widerstände gewonnen und
schließlich haben die Demokraten dort
auch bei den Zwischenwahlen im dezember
2022 das Rennen um den Senat gewonnen in
der Stichwahl in diesem Bundesstaat
stattfand weil keiner der Kandidaten
mehr als 50%
freundlichen Kandidaten Hersteller dies
war ein wichtiger politischer Sieg für
die beiden Regierung und ein großer
Rückschlag für die trump-kampagne
[Musik]
und das liegt daran dass Walker in
Georgia der einzige republikanische
Kandidat war der seine Wiederwahl 2022
nicht gewinnen konnte die anderen acht
landesweiten Wahlen in diesem
Bundesstaat darunter die das Gouverneurs
der Secretary of State eine Art
Innenminister des Bundesstaates und des
Generalstaatsanwalts und alle von
Republikanern mit großen Vorsprung
gewonnen mit anderen Worten Walker war
die Ausnahme die Anomalie und es stellt
sich die Frage was Walker von den
anderen republikanischen Kandidaten
Unterschied die anderen Kandidaten haben
sich von Trump entweder distanziert oder
ihn lieber
ignoriert tatsächlich wandte sich sogar
gewöhne Brian kämpft gegen den
ehemaligen Präsidenten indem er
argumentierte dass die
Präsidentschaftswahlen von 2020 sauber
gewesen sein und schon ehrlich verloren
habe
sollte von seinem Amt zurücktreten er
ist ein obstruktionist der sich weigert
zuzugeben dass wir in Georgia gewonnen
haben und zwar gewaltig da haben auch
die anderen Zwilling States gewonnen
Donald Trump oft Twitter das gilt
natürlich nicht nur für Georgia die
Zwischenwahlen waren eine schmerzhafte
Niederlage vertrauen
das Ausmaß könnt ihr auf dem Bildschirm
sehen von den 16 Kandidaten die für den
Senat das gouvernance Amt oder das Amt
des sekretary of state umkämpft der
Bundesstaaten kandidiert haben sind jene
die zum harten Kern der Trump Anhänger
gehören größtenteils kläglich
gescheitert nur zwei von ihnen haben
ihre Wahl gewonnen ihr müsst bedenken
dass dies die Lage in den umkämpften
Bundesstaaten war also jenen die beiden
2020 gewonnen hat starten die für die
republikanischen Ambitionen 2024 absolut
kriegsen entscheidend sind und das ist
mein kleines Beispiel für das schlechte
Abschneiden der Republikaner bei der
zwischenwahl die theoretisch für Sie
günstig aussah
tatsächlich erwarteten die Republikaner
eine große Welle von Wahl Siegen doch
dazu ist es letztendlich nicht gekommen
die Ergebnisse waren eindeutig die von
Trump aufgestellten Kandidaten viele von
ihnen Extremisten die die Slogans des
ehemaligen Präsidenten wiederholten
Schnitten besonders
schmerzhaft waren die Niederlagen der
Trump freundlichen senatskandidaten
black Masters in Arizona Adam in Nevada
Mehmet aus dem Pinsel wenn ja und Person
Walker in Georgia und das bringt uns
direkt zum ersten Hinweis darauf warum
die Dinge für den ehemaligen Präsidenten
dieses Mal anders laufen könnten es mag
Dich überraschen aber Trump ist eine
ziemlich verlierermaschine geworden
[Musik]
wer denkt das Trump das reinste
wahlkampfgenie seiner ein absolut
unfehlbares Zugpferd für seine Partei
der irrt gewaltig tatsächlich schaffte
er es bisher nur zwei Wahlen zu gewinnen
bei allen anderen war er eine Belastung
denn eine Hilfe so sitzt er sich einmal
bei den republikanischen Vorwahlen durch
ungewandern ebenfalls genau einmal die
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2016 allerdings
wie gesagt und das war's dann aber auch
danach ging es mit Trumps Wahl Glück
bergab er verlor die Zwischenwahlen von
2018 seine Wiederwahl 2020 und nun hat
er 2022 er erneut bei den Zwischenwahlen
einstecken müssen wenn wir Trump
abservieren werden wir anfangen Wahlen
zu gewinnen wenn wir bei Trump bleiben
werden wir weiterhin Wahlen verlieren so
sehen ich das Paul ryana
republikanischer Politiker ehemaliger
Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses und
vizepräsidentschaftskandidat von mit
Ronny ich weiß dass viele Leute in
unserer Partei den ehemaligen
Präsidenten lieben aber er ist wenn man
so will der
Markus für jemanden der die
Parlamentswahlen gewinnen will und
irgendwann müssten wir weiterziehen und
nach neuen Führungspersönlichkeiten
suchen die uns zum Sieg führen mit robny
Senator aus Utah als Trump 2015 seine
Kandidatur ankündigte retip-partei auf
einer riesigen republikanischen
Popularitätswelle die ihr 54 sanatoren
247 Sitze in Repräsentantenhaus und 31
Posten beschert hatte tja und heute
stehen sie an allen Fronten wesentlich
schlechter da es macht überraschen aber
die ERA Trump hat die Republikaner eine
Menge macht gekostet
dass der ehemalige Präsident als einer
der wenigen Präsidenten in der
Geschichte der Vereinigten Staaten seine
Wiederwahl nicht gewinnen konnte war
also kein großer Zufall tatsächlich
handelt es sich um einen relativ
unpopulären Kandidaten in allen Umfragen
liegt seine Missbilligung im Schnitt bei
55% schaut euch selber an
[Musik]
allerdings sieht es für Präsident Joe
beiden momentan auch nicht viel besser
aus nur 43% der Amerikaner stimmen mit
seiner Politik über ein 52 tun dies
nicht aber immerhin steht beiden ein
paar Prozentpunkte besser da als Trump
und das ist auch eine der Hauptgründe
warum die republikanische Parteiführung
fürchtet mit Trump als Kandidaten noch
mehr zu verlieren als bisher ihr Problem
bei der Partei Basis ist er ungebrochen
beliebt auch wenn sein potenzieller
widersache die Cent ist in zeitweise
überholt hat aber das ist natürlich
nicht der einzige wichtige Faktor der
erklärt warum dieser Wahlkampf für den
ehemaligen Präsidenten sehr kompliziert
werden könnte
der zweite wichtige Grund hat mit der
Tatsache zu tun dass er ganz auf sich
alleine gestellt ist eine Tatsache die
in den reinen Republikaner einige
Bedenken hervorruft kurz vor inzwischen
Wahlen hat Trump z.B eine Kampagne gegen
einen der größten republikanischen
Partei gestartet die Rede ist natürlich
von gerade erwähnten Gewinner von
Florida Ron dezentes
dieser ist ein ehemaliger Verbündeter
Trumps der in Florida kürzlich einen
großen Siedlungen hat und dessen
Popularität auch Landes bei dem Aufwind
ist nur ein Trump hat seine Konkurrenz
erkannt und ihn direkt genommen das
erklärt Nachricht wie diese Trump zieht
gegen die Säntis in den Krieg und nein
das ist kein Einzelfall ganz und gar
nicht
jedes Mal wenn ein führender Vertreter
der Republikaner sein Spiel nicht
mitspielt macht Trump diese Person zur
Zielscheibe egal wie stark dies die
Partei beschädigt der Fall des gehörlos
von Virginia kennen oder das was gerade
in Arizona passiert sind ebenfalls gute
Beispiele dafür im letzteren Fall hat
der trampismus mit Hilfe von
Organisationen wie turning point USA
versucht alle gemäßigten und alle
Kandidaten der alten republikanischen
Garten zu beseitigen wie genau dies
funktioniert haben wir wie gesagt im
vorhin erwähnten Video erklärt
stattdessen stellen sie viel
exaktiertere radikale daran Trump treuer
Kandidaten auf die unter anderem leugnen
dass die Vereinigten Staaten eine
Demokratie sind wir reden hier von einer
unkontrollierbaren Gruppe die auch bei
den Wahlen eine Katastrophe ist tatsache
ist das Trump seinen eigenen Weg geht
und ihr publikanische Partei zu einer
unterwürfigen Organisation machen will
die ihm voll und ganz zu Diensten ist
aufgrund des Drucks der durch Trump
aufgepatschten Basis ist es innerhalb
der republikanischen Partei momentan
sehr schwer aufzusteigen wenn man nicht
an die Truppen wie zum Beispiel die
wahlbetrugstheorie von 2020 glaubt
selbst die Center ist orientiert sich
daher Anton Spiel kopiert gar seine
Körpersprache bis ist klasse Teil und
versucht ihn bei manchen Themen gar
keinen punkto Radikalität zu übertreffen
aber dazu später mehr wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnte das alles für große
Unruhe immer nicht Trump Flügel der
Partei
[Musik]
aber kommen wir zum dritten Problem
Trumps das hat mit den vielen
Gerichtsverfahren zu tun mit denen sich
der ehemalige Präsident konfrontiert
sieht und nehmt euch in acht der das
geht nicht darum dass ein paar kleinere
Probleme hat nein Trump steckt bis zum
Hals im sumpfjuristischer Probleme vom
Diebstahl vertraulicher Dokumente rund
um Atomwaffen über seine
Mitverantwortung beim Angriff auf das
Kapitol bis hin zu Steuerproblemen aller
Art es ist sehr wahrscheinlich das Jump
auf der Anlagebank landen wird nur ein
paar Tage nach der ankündigen seine
Kandidatur ist das hier passiert
sechster dezember 2022 Trump
Organisation von New Yorker Gericht des
Steuerbetrugs für Schuldige Befunden
natürlich ist das nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs wir haben über Trumps
Geschäftspraktiken übrigens ein eigenes
Video gedreht und ich werde es euch
Verlinken auf jeden Fall sind dies die
drei Schlüsselfaktoren die bedeuten dass
der ehemalige Präsident dieses Mal nicht
mit dem Image eines Erfolgs an den Start
gehen kann und das hat natürlich
Konsequenzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sprechen sich zum Beispiel immer mehr
Republikaner dafür aus dass Blatt zu
wenden und das gilt sogar für einige
bekannte Trump Pisten eine wahre
Führungspersönlichkeit versteht wann sie
zu einer Belastung geworden ist eine
wahre Führungspersönlichkeit versteht
das ist Zeit ist von der Bühne
abzutreten und die Wähler haben uns
diese klare Botschaft gegeben wenn es am
Ziel ist Virginia Lieutenant Gabalier
sein eigener Vizepräsident der sich nach
dem Angriff auf das Kapitol immer wieder
von Trump distanzierte hat bereits
deutlich gemacht dass er diesen nicht
unterstützen wird es könnte jemand
anderen geben den ich mehr bevorzugen
würde Mike Pants zur Frage ob er 2024
für Trump stimmen würde und beachte dass
diese Ablehnung auch wichtige Spender
der Partei mit einschließt Dragon
Sportsman sagt dass er Donald Trumps
Präsidentschaftskandidatur nicht
unterstützen wird es ist an der Zeit
dass sich die republikanische Partei
einer neuen Generation von
Führungspersönlichkeiten zu verwendet
und ich beabsichtige eine von ihnen bei
den Vorwahlen zur Präsidentschaft zu
unterstützen Steven shortsman Gründer
von Blackstone der republikanische
megasponsor can Griff wenn der in diesen
Zyklus 60 Millionen Dollar in
republikanische Kampagnen gesteckt hat
nannte Trump einen dreifachen Verlierer
und sagte er solle nicht als Präsident
kandidieren wie ihr wisst entscheidet in
den USA vor allem das Geld über den
Ausgang von Wahlen mit ihrem
Kampagnen aber wir reden nicht nur von
Politikern und Großspendern sondern auch
von den Medien
[Musik]
Medien die Trump bisher unterstützt
haben die Fox und die New York Post
haben bereits ein Machtwort gesprochen
und wisst ihr was ich glaube dass dies
eine jene Momente ist in denen ein Bild
mehr sagt als tausend Worte so hat sie
nur Post damit begonnen schon
folgendermaßen zu behandeln und
vielleicht noch aufschlussreicher ist
dass sie beginnen Alternativen in
Betracht zu ziehen viele Rechte Medien
würden daher lieber Ronny sind es zum
neuen großen Star der republikanischen
Partei machen könnte er Donald Trumps
Ambitionen also einen schweren Schlag
versetzen sondern genau das schauen wir
uns jetzt an
die Cent ist der Trump Killer
der aus einer Mittelschichtfamilie
stammende Ron Disentis hat in Jehle und
Harvard studiert war in der US Navy als
militäranwalt tätig hat den Irakkrieg
gedient war Kongress Abgeordneter und
hat jetzt bei seiner Wiederwahl zum
gewonnene von Florida einen klaren Sieg
errungen dezentes hat es geschafft fast
60% der Stimmen zu holen in ein
Bundesstaat in dem die Demokraten bisher
durchaus als konkurrenzfähigkeiten ja
das wird in Zukunft wohl nicht mehr der
Fall sein denn er hat sie förmlich
niedergeist es war ein wahrer Triumph
alles andere als ein knapper Sieg über
Trump 2016
Punkte Vorsprung bei den hispanischen
Wählern was ihm einen beeindruckenden
Sieg in Miami day County ermöglichte
übrigens das erste Mal dass einer
Republikaner dies in den letzten zwei
Jahrzehnten geschafft hat wir werden
bald ein Video über den Gewinner von
Florida und seine politischen Position
hier auf visualpolitik drehen also
vergessen nicht uns zu abonnieren und
ganz wichtig das Glöckchen zu aktivieren
um über die Hintergründe und
Entwicklungen in der mächtigsten
Nationen dieses Planeten auf dem
Laufenden zu bleiben was für uns im
Moment wichtig ist ist das es sich bei
Disentis um einen sehr konservativen
Mann handelt der ist in einigen Umfragen
geschafft hat Trump zu überholen obwohl
er seine Kandidatur und seinen Wahlkampf
noch gar nicht offiziell begonnen hat
24 Februar 2023 rondi Säntis schlägt in
Umfrage Donald Trump um 24 Punkte die am
Mittwoch veröffentlichte Umfrage des
Meinungsforschungsinstituts VPE
intelligence ergab das 40% der
republikanischen Vorwahl Wähler
landesweit die centes als ihre erste
Wahl für die Kandidatur der Partei für
das Weiße Haus 2024 ansehen nur 31%
sehen Trump als ihre erste Wahl an der
Abstand vergrößerte sich noch als die
Wähler gebeten worden sich zwischen den
beiden zu entscheiden 57% entschieden
sich für die Säntis und 33% für Trump
Präsident Trump wird von den meisten
Republikanern immer noch gemocht aber
unsere Vorwahl Wähler sind pragmatisch
sagte vpn-chef Chris Wilson sie mögen
seine Politik sind aber der Meinung dass
die Partei ein neues Gesicht und einen
neuen Anführer braucht
[Musik]
wie gesagt noch handelt es sich um
einzelne umfragenwerte sollte die
Centers jedoch endlich den Schritt wagen
bei den Vorwahlen republikante zu
kandidieren könnte Trump gewaltig ins
Schwitzen kommen Trump war zum Beispiel
schon während seiner Präsidentschaft ein
starker Befürworter von corona-impfungen
bis heute brüstet er sich damit dass er
frühzeitig aber Milliarden von Dollar in
die Entwicklung von Impfstoffen
investiert und damit seinen Bürgern
genügend Impfdosen gesichert hat das
Thema spaltet jedoch nach wie vor die
Nationen vor allem die republikanische
Basis ist immer weniger davon überzeugt
dass alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen
ist die Skepsis gegen die corona-impfung
ist unter ihnen sehr hoch und nimmt mit
jeder neuen Enthüllung über die Skandale
der darin verwickelten Pharmaunternehmen
und Experten zu und die sind das hat
sich in dieser Sache schon frühzeitig
als Lockdown und impfgegnerpositioniert
die Regierung von Florida empfiehlt zum
Beispiel unter seiner Führung Kinder
unter 5 Jahren generell nicht gegen
COBIT impfen zu lassen die Frage ist
natürlich wird dieses Thema alleine
ausreichend um Trump zu besiegen und wir
sind der Meinung nein deswegen die Cent
ist natürlich noch weitere Pfeile gegen
Trump im Köcher hat aber wie gesagt das
werden wir in einem zukünftigen Video
genauer beleuchten schließlich
entscheidet die Frage der nächsten
US-Präsidentschaft nicht nur über das
Schicksal Amerikas sondern das der
ganzen Welt vergesst also bitte nicht
das Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen und mit
uns am Ball zu bleiben und wenn ihr das
erledigt habt seid ihr erstmal mit eurer
Meinung an der Reihe glaubt ihr das
schon 2024 wieder der Kandidat der
Republikaner sein wird haltet ihr es für
eine gute Idee dass er kandidiert oder
sollte er ein für alle Mal zurücktreten
und sich aus der Politik zurückziehen
was könnte unter einem neuen Präsidenten
Trump auf uns zukommen und was ist eure
generelle Meinung über ihn wie immer
sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass durch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt falls ja geht uns bitte ein Leid
und heißt auch mit euren Freunden damit
diese auch mit diskutieren können
natürlich freuen uns jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit uns dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]